all right y'all welcome back we've got
Tao here with
us you may know our next guest as
Elaine's boss Jay Peterman on Seinfeld
or as the voice of King Neptune on
SpongeBob SquarePants in my household uh
but to every dog lover out there he's
known as the host of the national dog
show which airs tomorrow Thanksgiving
Day on NBC please welcome John O'Hurley
along with a couple of his best friends
[Applause]
y'all
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my gosh I want to cuddle with you you
have a job okay great do a job your
character changed this is Annie and time
right here very cute I love that you
came with dogs are are you a dog person
did you have dogs growing up yes I did
yep yep many dogs and a canary you
remember one you remember one of them in
particular birds are hard in a household
Rex very original name my dog a Rex such
amazing name amazing I love when they
name him like old dudes like Bill like
well what's your favorite breed like at
the shows you've done so many over 20
years now 22 years we've been doing the
show yeah usually had killer show before
then but the um uh my favorite is the
Irish Setter oh neck is very erect
beautiful auburn hair on the blue rug as
it comes out it always looks like the
redhead that just walked into the
cocktail party there it is right there
you see oh it's just beautiful I love it
so it's it's like I said it's not a dog
I would own it's been over why well
they're very active I mean you need a
lot of property to have a yeah I mean
they're they're meant to be bird dogs
yeah so they're as opposed to you that's
very respectful so wait over 20 years
what's like one of the most memorable
moments at the dog show well are you I
would I would say the uh oh gosh a few
years back during the best in show round
which is where the top seven dogs are
there one of them is going to be chosen
Best in Show and it's the Great Dane
that happens to be sauntering by the NBC
Booth stops in its tracks looks me
straight in the eye squats down and
leaves what I would refer to as an
editorial comment right on the floor
right there and it stopped the entire
show while the HazMat team comes out
with the elephant shovels and has to
clean things up the only way this story
gets even better is if that dog won Best
in Show it's it's kind of self-
disqualifying unfortunately oh man would
have been funny though that's right do
you remember when they first asked you
to host because it was such a random
thing right well yes I they uh they
asked me to host uh and they didn't know
what everybody was Flying Blind the
first year including me cuz I had never
been to a dog show I don't know anything
about him they brought the old English
sheep dog up to the judge it you don't
know what an Old English sheep dog is
it's uh it's yeah it's 80 lbs of hair
and 2 lbs of actual dog yeah so they
brought it up to the judge who was this
elegantly gowned woman so she walks
around to the front of the dog and she
starts picking through all of the hair
on the dog's head and I said David what
is she doing now he says John she's
trying to find the
eyes to gauge the attentiveness of the
dog I said really I said well she picks
through all of that hair and she finds
only one eye she's got the wrong end of
the
door so you see how far my learning
curve was that was on air right yeah oh
yeah I love you so much and and it
turned into the you know they have the
broadcasters comments in the sports
section in USA Today that was it wrong
into of the dog John O
her okay so you have a you have such a
great voice so have you ever done do you
want to I think dog wants to go for a
walk
oh my God I love you so
much she said she said to the dog turn
around back take oh my God for your
morning out for your morning
Constitution were you physical comedy is
the best oh my God I love you so much
now don't you try
that uh be sure to watch the national
dog show tomorrow along with my sister
who never misses it Thanksgiving Day on
[Music]
[Applause]
NBC thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home